Venom 3 with Tom Hardy is going to be
his final Venom film and with the way
Venom 2 left us off in the post-credit
scene and the way Spider-Man no way home
left us off with its post-credit scene a
lot of people are wondering what exactly
is in store for the future of Venom both
in the Sony spiderverse and in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe well we know a
few things about the villain of the
movie or I should say villains of the
movie thanks to some Insider reports and
the villains actually have a interesting
connection to Iron Man and they do also
have a connection to Spider-Man if
you've been following the channel and
the news about Venom 3 you probably have
heard that Tom Hardy has said multiple
times that the end goal for Venom would
be to have him and Spider-Man get
together on screen well this is Tom
Hardy's final film as Venom at least his
final solo film so a lot of fans are
wondering are we going to see Spider-Man
in venom 3 if not when not too long ago
The Insider my time to shine hello
stated that we are going to see Tom
Hardy's Venom go up against Tom
Holland's Spider-Man and she said that
is coming sooner than we think but did
not clarify if it's in venom 3 or
another project so let's go over what we
know right now about Venom 3 the
villains and their Iron Man and
Spider-Man connections and if you're new
and you want to stay up to date on Venom
Spider-Man the MCU and Marvel in general
be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell and if you subscribe
and leave a comment on our videos you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items winner picks one item and we pick
one winner at the end of each month so
according to The Insider my time to
shine hello this is indeed going to be
the final solo Venom film she did
specifically say solo film so Sony or
Marvel could have some plans for Venom
to appear in another movie perhaps
Avengers Secret Wars or the big
spiderverse movie that Sony could be
planning she states that Orwell Taylor
is the main villain and he will be
played by chiel a Geor this was also
reported by Insider Daniel rbk most
Marvel fans know cha tell from Doctor
Strange and then of course again in
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness MTO well looks like he's
sticking with Marvel kind of because
this of course is Sony and Marvel and is
going to be playing the villain Orwell
Taylor now when this news broke out some
people were a little bit confused
because he's not a symbiote he's
obviously not a symbiote from clintar so
what's the deal is Venom not going to
fight another symbiote in this film well
since Riot was in the first film and
then Carnage was in the second film we
are assuming that some type of symbiote
is going to show up in venom 3 we're not
sure who but we assume one is showing up
but at the same time Spider-Man could
fill the hole of a missing symbiote but
hopefully both show up and I'll talk
about how both a symbiote and Spider-Man
could be related to Orwell Taylor the
main villain of this film plus some
other villains come along with him as
well that have that Iron Man connection
that I mentioned you see Orwell Taylor
was once a general in the United States
Army but he becomes a villain because of
one of his sons Hugh Taylor who was also
in the Army then he quit the Army and
went to work in the superhero prison
that everybody knows as the Vault sadly
Hugh would get smothered to death by
Venom so his father Orwell wants to find
a way to avenge the death of his son so
he sets out to kill Venom so Orwell
gathers together friends of his son and
his other son Maxwell to set out and
kill Venom Hugh's two buddies and fellow
Guardsmen at the Vault Samuel caulin and
Curtis Elkin get fitted with armor that
was based off of the armor that the
Guardsman wore with which was based off
of designs stolen from Iron Man so their
armor is based off of Iron Man's armor
so Samuel culin goes on to become
ramshot and Curtis Elkins becomes
century and his other son Maxwell
becomes Screech Orwell calls this group
the jury and their mission is to bring
Venom to Justice this will be really
interesting to see how Sony adapts armor
that is supposed to be stolen from Iron
Man the designs for the armor are
supposed to be based off of Iron Man
suits so of course Sony can't mention
Iron Man in these films they can't
mention Tony Stark they don't have the
rights to do that but we'll know when we
see these suits that they're based off
of Iron Man so that'll be pretty cool
but like I mentioned everybody wants to
know about the Symbiote that's going to
be in the film and about of course
Spider-Man we'll talk about both of
these in just a bit but first big thank
you to fume for sponsoring this video
fume is a game changer for a lot of
people in turning bad habits into good
habits a lot of people struggle with
these bad habits but fume looks at these
in a different way not everything in the
habit is wrong so instead of a drastic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad from your habit and that's
exactly what fume does they're
Innovative and they're award-winning and
they're a flavored air device that's all
it is it's flavored air so it has none
of the bad things in the bad habit in it
instead of vapor it uses flavored Air
instead of electronics fume is
completely natural and instead of
harmful chemicals fume uses delicious
flavors I had actually heard really
great things about fume from my friends
who were struggling with some bad habits
they actually raved about it and how it
helped them which is why I agreed to
partner with them and they sent me some
samples and they honestly are super
refreshing and taste very flavorful and
good and it comes in beautiful real wood
and it's honestly really fun to just sit
there and kind of fidget with if you're
someone who likes to fidget like I do
and I know stopping is something we all
put off because it's hard but but with
fume it's easy and they have served over
150,000 customers and have thousands of
success stories and that could be you if
you pick up a journey pack today head
over to trif nume.com and use code
Cosmic to save 10% off when you get the
journey pack today that's trfu m.com and
use code Cosmic to save an additional
10% off your order today now obviously
one big connection that they could do
with Spider-Man and with Iron Man is if
Tom Holland Spider-Man showed up in
venom 3 if Marvel Studios gave them
permission to do that then Tom Holland
could look at these villains and say
wait are these suits Iron Man suits are
these stolen Stark Tech in which Venom
might not know what that is and Orwell
Taylor might not know what that is
either but that could be a really clever
way for them to do it Spider-Man could
get involved because in the comics
Orwell Taylor and the jury his team do
kidnap Spider-Man however there is kind
of a flaw with this story being played
out in the Sony Spider-Man universe you
see in the comment the jury kidnaps and
drugs Spider-Man this is because he
brought the Venom symbiote to Earth and
as we know that is not what happened in
the Sony Spider-Man universe that's a
big thing that a lot of people are still
mad about but we'll just move along the
jury also when they kidnap and Drug
Spider-Man trick him into helping them
steal a government transport array they
plan to use this and modify it to be
able to kill Venom of course they fail
but what's really interesting is that
this team does encounter Spider-Man on
their way to try and kill Venom it's
interesting because of what Venom 2 and
Spider-Man no way home left us with in
their post credit scenes Eddie Brock and
Venom now know that Spider-Man exist at
least in that universe that they were in
so in their own Universe they are most
likely going to want to track down
Spider-Man Peter Parker and of course
there is always a chance that Orwell
Taylor might think that Spider-Man
himself is also a Venom symbiote and it
would make sense that Orwell would want
to kill all symbiotes maybe something
happened with Riot maybe something
happened with Carnage as well maybe when
Venom was fighting Carnage he
accidentally killed Orwell Sun there's
many ways they could play this story
that would make a lot of sense and it
would make sense giving how Spider-Man
and Venom somewhat move alike that
Orwell could think Spider-Man is indeed
a symbiote as well and this could be how
we get a Spider-Man in venom 3 now I'm
not sure if that's going to be Tom
Holland Spider-Man or not after all The
Insider my time to shine hello did say
that Andrew Garfield would be returning
she did not specifically say where he is
going to return a wi project she simply
said he will show up in other stuff and
not to mention when Spider-Man no way
home came out a lot of insiders at that
time did state that Sony does want
Andrew Garfield back and Andrew Garfield
is down to return and play more
Spider-Man even though he said he's not
but then again he did also state that he
was not in Spider-Man Noy home and that
he wasn't the werewolf and we know how
that turned out now as far as another
symbiote being in venom 3 I would assume
that we'll get another symbiote even if
Spider-Man is in the film they'll
probably want a symbiote to bring Venom
and Spider-Man together to have to
defeat Because unless Orwell Taylor
really does have actual Iron Man
technology Venom and Spider-Man taking
down the group The Jury shouldn't be
that hard but what would be hard is
another symbiote Tom Hardy said that if
they're in the Olympics then the gold
medal is Spider-Man Spider-Man and Venom
in a movie and he would be foolish not
to go for gold we'll see if that
actually happens in venom 3 if we hear
anything else about Spider-Man in venom
3 or just simply any Venom 3 News we'll
be sure to do an update videos so be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell so you don't miss out
on any of the Venom 3 videos please
don't forget to give this video a like
you can also follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof